HOCKEY LEAGUE IN GOAL
THE POWER PLAY.
MEANWHILE IN THE MONTH OF APRIL,
THE: WHEN THINGS DON'T GO
WELL FOR A PLAYER, THEY NEVER GO
WILL BE OUT FOR ANOTHER 1:22. BE
82.2% OF
THE TIME THEY KILL IT.
IN THE GAME AGAINST THE NEW YORK
ISLANDERS.
LOOK AT THIS LITTLE LOOK HE
PENALTY.
>> Sean: McAVOY TO MARCHAND.
40 SECONDS TO GO IN THE PERIOD.X
A LITTLE MORE OPEN ICE EACH HAL.
THIS ISTOO.
>> Sean: BOX TOP OF THE CIRCLE.
TRIED TO GO CROSS  IS BLOCKED
AND NOW LINDGREN'S GOING TO
TURN, PIVOT, AND TRY TOLAZAR.
TROUBA WEAVES A CORNER SHOT AWA
ZIBANEJAD.
HERE'S JAKE DeBRUSK.
HE'S GOING TO
OUTPLAYED BY ULLMARK, WHICH
THE NEW YORK RANGERS, THIS IS
THEIR FINAL ROAD GAME OF THE
THE PUCK.
SEVEN GOALS SINCE BRUCE
CASSIDY MENTIONED --
IT WAS A LONG SHIFT FOR THOSE
RANGERS.
THEY'RE EXHAUSTED AS THEYUCK BY
DeBRUSK.
OUT OF THE BOX COMES TROUBA. IT
MOMENT.
BUT IT'S PLAYED BACK OUT BY FOX,
THAT WAS AGAINST EDMONTOND
HE'S GOING TO GET IT.
DELAYED PENALTY, AND A GOAL! HI,
THAT OPENS UP A CLEAR
11:30 TO GO IN REGULATION, 2-1,
BOSTON.
FINALL COYLE.
PASS TOO HOT TO HANDLE.
PLAYED OFF THE BACK WALL BY
CHARLIE COYLE.
CLIFTON SENDING THIS PUCK DOWN
THE ICE N BEHIND FOR
ZIBANEJAD.
LINDHOLM SAW THAT COMING.
ZIBANEJAD AND FOR HIM,
BUT HE'S BEEN REALLY